[Music]
yes it's time to pick on Stephen King
again with the Tommyknockers poor
Stephen King why do I pick on him so
much why do his miniseries give me so
much joy I know he's written good stuff
but the bad stuff is just so
entertaining he's returning cliches and
overuse of character traits often
transfer is so poorly into film and I'll
enough the more time they have to
explain and analyze it saying it over
two and a half hour long TV special
usually the more horrible it is what's
that why yes that is an ass numbing Lee
long time so let's not beat around the
bush let's dive right into it the
Tommyknockers so our story takes place
in go ahead and take a shot as for me I
can't play this Stephen King drinking
game anymore unless survived but hey
that doesn't mean I still can't plug it
with a brand new home version you won't
ever have to worry about watching a
Stephen King miniseries sober or awake
ever again
it comes complete with beer glasses cool
toys baseball hats and even your very
own talking mister to me doll so in the
state of Maine were introduced to hilly
and he's excited because his grandpa
just got him a magic kit well dad says
there's no such thing as magic kids and
old people we know that magics real no
matter what anybody says there is even a
place that's magic out by the Anderson
farmer and my day we called it big
engine woods but it's called burning
woods now but no matter what it's called
there's magic there the Injuns believed
it but keep going
magic spirits you have to keep you
what's about you when you go there
nearly never never go there alone you
know my grandpa told me a story like
that too he also ate sandpaper and
called himself an esse but I still
believed him and seeing how this is a
Stephen King story we cut to one of the
other umpteen gazillion characters
this is officer Li and she's showing the
kids around the station for a field trip
this this is where we have ourselves and
we put all the people who break the law
in here that man over there used to
molest little children just like you go
ahead touch it go ahead touch it okay
come on I'm here let's go see the
schoolroom this is the best part I see
when I was a little girl my parents used
to travel a lot every time they went to
a new country they would bring me
another doll happy oh yes they are my
hobby my friends know that I like them
so every time they travel and suddenly
this character got disturbing and
uncomfortable seriously what police
station would allow dolls inside the
office we don't want break-ins in that
dude that's all right
sorry Joe Joe has never been broken this
is beyond a creepy hobby this is just an
Irving does your work a little bit Brian
um I was wondering to do was it all
possible for you to by any chance get
the report done by this Thursday well
we'll have to ask Roger before I can
answer that what do you think Roger
no I tried go
okay one of the children come Anton this
actually gets scared of one of the dolls
[Music]
to be fair that does look more realistic
than the Joe us three short tell you
what why don't you come back some other
time when we'll see them together okay
all alone just you and me does she not
know how creepy this looks you know what
the weird thing is the really freaking
out there thing all throughout the rest
of the movie she's totally normal
she's easygoing laid-back a nice person
there's nothing odd about her in the
least except for that one really
fucked-up thing but aside from that
nothing they said normal people are just
people you don't know very well well
then by god I don't want to know her
very well we didn't cut to esteem a post
office where you can clearly see a red
flag always stays up around here honey
I'm sorry I really I I think I'm gonna
have to work late tonight Oh Jill come
on yeah honey I will honey I will I
gotta go now
are you ready am I ready is that your
question am I ready it's like the sign
says neither snow nor rain nor oh yeah
now this is why The Postman Always Rings
Twice except he's about to find out that
the mail lady really is a mail lady mal
oh sorry I thought this was a port oh
this is how most of them start out no
it's a Stephen King miniseries Oh
condolences Thanks we then cut to a
writer named Bobby who stumbles across
something very odd our backyard
[Music]
well that's going on we cut to a poet
play by Jimmy Smits who isn't an
alcoholic really I haven't had a drink
in about a year now
Jesus we got all the callback characters
in check why don't we just send the cast
that appears in every Stephen King movie
of course there's no
[Music]
some dumb presents a disappointing
resolution so Smits is upset because he
feels his alcoholism is keeping him from
writing any new work and he often talks
about it with Bobby as apparently they
used to be an item but she currently has
her own problems like how her dog is
acting strange after getting zapped by
that radioactive muffler I mean a
parakeet is one thing but an owl a cobra
a fucking Komodo dragon what the hell
can't a kid just play some ball with his
ferocious killer Komodo dragon for just
one moment
so submits gets in front of a crowd of
leads to an awaiting public he reads
specifically to the ethnicities of Maine
who seemed to take up these three seats
right here and the people applauded what
don't white however not everybody is
amused
I pay you to read new poetry not old
stuff when the last poem you wrote that
got published you're nothing but a drunk
gardener always were always will be
he's not gonna take any event he's gonna
show her that he's not a drunk by when
we had some bucket of that getting
royally plastered that'll show her
shall we maybe go upstairs so just give
everybody a treat and do it right here
on the rug I'm going to see to it that
you'll never work again this is a new
one a writer who's an alcoholic is such
an odd combination
Caramba no he's been taking fencing
lessons from burgess Meredith nuking sob
if you remember nothing else in this
world remember this God oh well there's
only one thing defied way to exit the
scene I'm sorry I know we're supposed to
feel sorry for him but that's like the
ending to a goofy cartoon he winds up on
a beach after a drunken rampage and is
picked up by Officer who's going in
there who takes him back home well
that's going on
Hilly's brother is frightened by
something he hears making noise in the
closet
[Music]
don't listen to him just play your
delicious flames back to sleep dupa dupa
don't worry
but he'll he doesn't see any monster and
tells his brother to go back to sleep
can I sleep in your bed tonight sure
that could go all warm and safe and
toasty the way he said that
and I don't like the way he's snuggling
with him either you don't mean this sick
do you know that mean you're very sick
so we see the cheating postman out again
as his wife
deputy Olive Oyl reminds him that he
forgot his sandwiches for you and the
boys oh you're fishing well as bad as he
is at least he appreciates the fact that
his wife made him sandwich oh oh my god
he mixed the sandwiches tall Cheney wife
is one thing but throwing her sandwiches
out the window you are a bad bad man
then hop on in and let's see what we can
catch ah so well he's getting a good
look at her Tommyknockers Smiths meets
up with Bobby who tells him that the
strange device she started digging up
seems to be making her smarter not only
does she fix the plumbing in the house
but she also manages to take the water
heater apart and fix that too as I
uncover it it's ending up with some kind
of transmission I've turned in you an
Einstein huh now I have no idea how I
got that out what are you to do work I
just know as they were doing everything
Sinclair Isabel
God makes women good at plumbing and
machinery if this thing takes away
witness fear of spiders men are gonna
have no use on this planet at all
let's experience it again as you'll see
she's not the only one getting the
invention buggin Chile olive oil and
even the post ho all seem to be friggin
geniuses
which might not be good news for mister
adulterer you still love me Joe what
kind of a dim bulb question is that
anyway no you crazy why are you so mean
to me why so mean are you going how dare
you asking that question I'm going out
now and I'll be back when I want to you
got it Joe fuck but see I never want to
hear that word again I never want to
hear but again because but is what a
goat has for brains and but is for the
small-minded people in this small-minded
town and but is what you say when you
want to get away from your stupid wife
guy first the sandwiches now laughing
evilly while he's off to have an affair
even third of a derp would be like dude
you're fucking us but olive oil seems to
give some advice from an unlikely source
listen Becca Joe he's been cheating on
you okay chances fly TVs don't talk it
appears that this one does he's having
an affair you got it Oh what am I gonna
do kill him kill him hello now you might
be thinking to yourself that's taking
this way to comfortably well but let me
tell you when your TV comes to light
there's no point in arguing I know trust
me
listen I'll make him an offer he can't
she's asleep hold on he caught you
trying to tell a story here pay
attention don't even think about
changing the channel I got a hit man
pointing a gun at you right now there's
no point in calling the cops and cancel
your phone service an hour ago
and it's useless to get up from your
chair seeing how I'll kill your mother
if you do but I guess that doesn't
matter because I reek the house to
explode in just a few seconds
happy Halloween sleepy so as these two
continue to dig up the lost city of
Tetris Mitch finally realizes maybe it's
best to call the police guard they will
come here with with trucks filled with
barbed wire and men with guns and a gag
us guard and you know that they would do
it et it's a two-story all the feds will
come over here they'll take all their
stuff away and then all the cons will
turn into walkie-talkies it'll be weird
and speaking of weird Hilly's a magic
trick using the invention that the
crocodile tongue seemed to help create
seems to do its job a little too well as
meets his brother disappear but then
never brings him back pili you stop
fooling around and get baby back now try
but I can try okay
hey where is he where did he go no I
don't know where things go when they
stop being here
we come back it's okay I'm sure he just
went to another dimension right within
the realms of Outworld no mine see he's
in good hands but it turns out the
brother really has disappeared and
nobody can find him so the whole entire
town shows up all 12 of them to help
track him down however they can all
except for a one person who had to go
home early
Oh Joe left the search early said he was
coming now with the flu no he can't be
he seriously can't be I'll be back first
thing in the morning okay
thanks Becca I'm going to puke up my
lunch if he is actually oh my god you
left a search for a lost child to fuck
the mail lady first the sandwiches then
the evil laughter now abandoning a child
to get laid dude you're not gonna find
the kid in her vagina
yeah at Becca's gonna be manning those
phones day and night until I find him
[Music]
I can't take this guy I really can't he
isn't just an asshole
he's like a compilation of assholes to
make the world's biggest asshole the six
million dollar ass all gentlemen we can
rebuild it we have the technology we
will take elements from the world's
biggest dick horses and make him
shittier than he ever was before
shitty crappier it's too great but olive
oil decide she can't take it anymore
and sets up a trap for the dick Meister
will you burn this junk off I mean I
hate this song turn it off yourself I
said you could hey now you don't mean
that
it's the crackers talking
Oh No Isis Listerine
make sure my coffin is minty fresh and
the inventions keep on coming as Bobby
it appears put together a typewriting
machine that actually writes the story
while she's asleep
I make us Stephen King joke here but
let's face it you've already made it in
your head but things get even worse when
Hayley suddenly slips into a coma take
him to the hospital Terry no no no you
two stay here
I'll take heavy to the hospital our fog
is through the first book with the
doctor yes trust the guy who believes an
engine magic with the safety of your
child
[Music]
just where is the hospital you may ask
oh good thank you they have a real good
health plan down there whatever a kid is
in trouble they just walk inside their
house and pretend like nothing is going
on comeback continuity Lords that's what
you can see olive oil was put in the
nuthouse and it seems like the rest of
the town it's not too far behind not
only is everybody making more dr. Seuss
inventions but many of them start
becoming psychic and acting more crazy I
know a psychic in a Stephen King story
alert the media what was it you wanted
well if you're gonna read my mind like
everybody else
I'm not getting it the only one who
doesn't seem to be affected by it is
Smith's it's he had a metal plate put in
his head years ago that they think
blocks off part of his brain only the
part that said say no to Star Wars
prequels you okay yeah I just needed a
good night's sleep way to dig I think
you should really took a good look at
yourself why you obsessed you can't stop
I can't stop what are you gonna playing
you're obsessed and you can't stop I can
stop when I want
oh so Ruth starts to catch on as well
and tries calling for Becca and seeing
how she's doing it in the doll room I
bet you'll never figure out where this
is going what a shot
[Music]
daaamn fuck with it Chuck I bet you
thought those dolls were just gonna sit
there nice and quiet all throughout this
Stephen King story didn't yeah but nope
they hide her body and disappear off to
puppetmaster 12 or something and
meanwhile the post tow has been doing
some inventing as well and she tries her
new invention on a pair of dim-witted
cops is he always so mean and grumpy is
he like that do you do too
just me
I've got that officer I thought you big
words in front of pretty ladies sound
like Randy Newman I just wish you'd
known better than to come snooping
around like this hold right there now
and do as he says ma'am we wouldn't
start belated from putting on a little
lipstick would you
oh no that's true we do have to let a
woman put on her lipstick it's like rule
22 bye bye boys
[Music]
really a lipstick death-ray we're
actually writing in a lipstick death-ray
this is Phil eva by Stephen King
standards did they just want a reason to
steal the effects from the 1960 Star
Trek show tell me the scene where she
fights Gorn is coming up next to
disappearances in one week that's more
than the coin sense it just vanished
into thin air without a trace butch you
ever heard of the Tommyknockers yo hey
the title of the movie just two hours in
and we're finally gonna figure out what
it is let's see last night and the night
before Tommyknockers Tommyknockers
knocking at my door you said yourself it
was as if they had vanished into thin
air well I'll think about it if anything
else occurs to you give me a call well
that explained everything sure he's
gonna rough up mr. Boogedy and the
Leprechaun people to find out their
location or is this gonna be like every
other Stephen King story where if he
makes up a name for something that
already has a name like The Shining is
just psychic it is just an alien or
Langille ears was okay you can keep that
one but to be fair we didn't want it
[Music]
so everyone gathers around the Church of
Celina as everyone is hypnotized by the
lean mean green machine to keep digging
it up the time for all of us to unite is
it hat
are you ready to complete the becoming
is that sort of like the happening only
funnier
but the crowd heard that in name whisper
capture Smits and forces him to start
digging up the device meanwhile grandpa
and the officer returned to check on the
town only to find that it's completely
abandoned but hey that doesn't mean they
can't stop for a nice cold one they
booby-trapped a Coke machine you know
about like a mine in the road or
something like that I mean this is
goofily abstract what-if military forces
are thirsty
dad thank the coffee yet
this is good this is really good cuz
this gives me a chance to properly
explain what frying to coke is mmm it's
when somebody does something so stupid
or phenomenally over-the-top that you
can't help but find it unbelievably
awesome and by god what is more awesome
than being killed by an exploding soda
machine created by glowing Nickelodeon
slime aside from a tiger stepping out of
mine in the Coliseum where I'll code
machine is your own salvation but aside
from that no so profit goes deeper into
the woods to find the evil diggers at
first I thought it was weird that he
didn't go back and try to get help but
then again I guess it would sound odd
telling a police officer that a Coke
machine ate your friend and there's a
coal trying to take effect of cooler so
maybe he made the right choice but he
gets captured too and it seems like
Smits is the only one left to save the
day he convinces Bobby that he's turned
to their side and that only the two of
them should be allowed to finish the
digging and see what's inside
just what is inside the machine the
TARDIS from Doctor Who no no that'd be
somewhat creative no it's just aliens
that's it they crash-landed and have
been here for years eating up people so
they can repopulate eating people help
them repopulate why is the town only now
being hypnotised by them why do
intelligent life-forms always seem to
crash their ships never explained
they're just aliens they're just weird
but they do find some of the missing
people including Hilly's brother worst
magic trick ever so it's kind of
confusing but I guess myths throws the
toys-r-us alien off the wheel and takes
control of the ship with his mind what
did the aliens try to stop him which is
weird why did they stop it when he first
came in but Smits matches to get the
ship up a choke and blows it to hell
with him inside
[Music]
and that's where it ends I shouldn't
really say n just more stops and with
that said kids I must ask the question
what have we learned today well I
learned there's a rumor that Stephen
King wrote this while high off his ass
honestly I wouldn't doubt it I mean yeah
it's stupid silly and makes little sense
but it's also kind of like looking into
somebody's psyche most of the story is
talking about how a certain substance
increases your creativity but also
increases your dependence much like King
admitted that's what happened when he
was a stoned alcoholic so in that sense
it's actually sort of fascinating seeing
one guy trying to get rid of his
dependency while also trying to make
others beat theirs but taking that out
of it this actually is one of the more
entertaining Stephen King minis it's
just based off of its coziness as usual
it's a lot of build-up to a
disappointing payoff but the build-up is
always good and the over-the-top
delivery is a ton of fun to watch
honestly I'd say give it a watch just
don't play the drinking game while
watching it your lungs will dissipate
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and nostalgia
ween is on the way
[Music]
while warm and safe and toasty
you